We will now talk about the adaptive immune system that has to do with B. lymphocytes.
Lymphocytes B or, briefly, B cells - I will draw them in blue.
Let's say this is one lymphocyte B.
It belongs to the group of white blood cells, called lymphocytes.
It is a backbone background
even though the name B comes from Bursa Fabricius,
but we will not stop at these details this time.
All of these cells are characterized by the appearance of protein on the surface.
Specifically, about 10,000 proteins.
I feel excited by the B cells and will soon discover why,
contains all these proteins and looks something like that.
I draw some of them.
Indeed these are the protein complexes that you can see.
Actually, they are 4 distinct groups of proteins
and these proteins will call membrane antibodies (membrane-bound).
In the following I will speak and explain more about antibodies.
Surely you have heard about antibodies
You have antibodies to different gut, or for different viruses
which I will clarify in the future,
but antibodies are really the only protein.
They are often referred to as immunoglobulins.
In fact, the two terms are equivalent.
Antibodies or immunoglobulins - are simply proteins.
Now, these proteins are found on the surface or membrane of B cells.
So they are connected to the membrane.
Usually when people talk about antibodies
they refer to free moving antibodies, for example. here.
I will clarify in more detail that they are produced.
What's more and more important and interesting for membrane antibodies
and B cells in particular is that
B cells contain a type of membrane antibody.
Of course it also contains antibodies, but those antibodies are different.
So we will focus on this change.
First I will draw the same color and
will explain exactly what they are different.
These two are cell B.
Both contain antibodies.
Interesting thing is that from a cell B to another cell B,
differ in this antibody
which can take many varied forms.
So it may look like that.
So these extensions - will be further deepened.
Fixed parts, imagine green is for each antibody,
and there is a variable variable part.
Perhaps the variable part of this cell is ---
will be dyed in pink color.
Each membrane bound antibody
will have the same variable parts.
Next cell B will have it
variable variable parts.
I will emphasize it with another color.
I will color it in a sealed purple color.
So variable parts are different.
Now it has 10,000 of that, and each of them
has the same variables (changes),
but they are all different from this B cell.
In fact there are about 10 billion combinations of
these variables.
So the first question - I still have no idea what to do
serve these variables - is how they are likely to appear
so many combinations?
As these proteins seem - maybe not so obvious,
all these proteins that are part of the majority of the cells
are produced by the genes of that cell.
If I draw it - this is the nucleus.
DNA is found inside the nucleus.
This cell has a nucleus.
There is also DNA in the nucleus.
If both cells are cell B and they come from
the same German line, I think they come from the same line of basic cells,
should they have the same DNA?
If they have the same DNA then why these proteins
are so different?
How do they change?
For this I consider cells B, you will see that this is worth
even for T-fascinating cells, in their development,
during hematopoiesis
- has to do with the development of lymphocytes.
At a stage of development,
there is a mixture of DNA
coded here, for these proteins.
So there is a great mix.
In most of the cases when we talk about DNA, we really do
we want to keep the information, not to have a mix.
But when these lymphocytes, when these B cells are mature,
or during a phase of their maturity or development,
there is an intentional mixture
of DNA that encodes this part and this part.
And that is what causes all this diversity
of these variables (changes)
membrane immunoglobulins.
We will now understand why all this diversity.
So there are so many things that can infect our body.
Viruses mutate and evolve, as well as bacteria.
I never know what can enter your body.
So what the immune system has done through cells B,
this also applies to cells T, it is
which has made a pile of combinations of these things
which can relate to what they will find.
Let's suppose a new virus
newly introduced?
The world has never heard of this virus, but cell B
will encounter this virus and this virus will not be linked.
Another cell B will meet the same virus
and again nothing will be connected.
Supposing that a few thousand B cells will belong to the same virus
and will not tie it, but since I have so much cell B
and having so many combinations of these variables
in these receptors, eventually one of the B cells
you will know him and tie him up.
It is assumed that this is what B cell is.
It will be related to the superficial part of the virus.
It can also be part of the bacterium,
or superficial part of any foreign protein.
And that surface-related bacterium - probably linked to that part of the bacterium--
this is called
epitope.
So if this cell is related to a foreign pathogen,
remember, other B cells do not - just that cell
with the given combination,
tenth of a tenth.
There really are not tithing dozens of combinations.
During their development, they examine everything
possible combinations of things that essence know,
to which there will be no reaction of the immune system.
In other words, combinations of self-reanimation
and crinkling.
So there really are not tithing tens or ten billion combinations
so something less than that.
It is also necessary to remove all combinations which
connect their cells, but still a great number
of the combinations they can link to
at least part of the pathogens of any
virus or bacteria.
As soon as one of these B cells binds, say,
friend, I'm fortunate enough to fit this
the new pathogen.
It is activated after it is linked to the new pathogens.
I'll explain the details later.
In order to activate, it is normally needed
help from assistive cell, but I do not want to stretch it
and hack into this video.
So in this case, I suppose activation
can happen - or say the need to be responsive,
is signaled by
connection with pathogens.
In most cases, you also need help
Auxiliary T cells as well.
So let's discuss why this is important.
Indeed, it is a defensive mechanism against failure
for the immune system
But once it is activated, it will start
to clone / copy myself.
It means, look, I'm the one that suits the virus
and will begin to cling to yourself.
It will begin to split and renew itself.
In the end there will be many versions of it.
Then all will replicate and differentiate,
differentiation means the specification of the role that it will have.
There are two forms of differentiation.
So they will be produced
hundreds of thousands.
Some of these cells will move into memory cells,
which really are cell B but which will be found for a long time
with the perfect receptor, with the perfect variable
of the receptor itself.
Some of the memory cells will be in quantity
bigger than they were at the beginning.
If the same pathogen attacks the organism in the next ten years
they will face more memory B cells
with which to come and which will be activated
and some of them will be shaded
into the effector cells.
Effective cells are usually cells
do, something is going on.
What the effector cells do is that they shine in the antibodies
they are restored to the B-effected cells - sometimes called
plasma cells.
They are fed into antibody factories.
The antibodies that they produce are the correct combination
of the initial combination, on the day it is formed,
as they are membrane antibodies.
So they will begin to produce these antibodies
for which we have spoken, with specificity - they will start you
secretes out these antibodies.
They will secretly emit hundreds of thousands of dollars
these proteins that are specific and have the ability
to relate to the new pathogen, this is a new pathogen.
So an effector cell will produce
2000 antibodies per second.
So you can imagine, if you have so many cell phones,
you will have so many antibodies in your body
and in different tissues.
The value of this and why the adaptive immune system is
that there are many viruses that infect your body,
but now you produce so much
antibodies.
Effective cells are these factories and these
specific antibodies will begin to recognize and bind the pathogens.
Wait to draw this.
Specific antibodies will bind these viruses
and this has some value.
First of all, identification.
Phagocytosis - this is called opsonization.
When a molecule is identified, it becomes easier
that phagocytes eat them, that's why persian
antibodies bind and signal phagocytes, which they do
the whole process lighter.
You should eat this "type".
It also complicates the functioning of viruses.
I have this great thing that has climbed to me.
It will be more difficult for them to infiltrate other cells,
in each of these antibodies,
are two identical and heavy chains
two light indenting chains.
Then they have a specific variable
in each of these two branches that can be linked
with the epitopes of the virus.
So you can imagine what happens if these cells relate to
an epitope and this cell is related to another virus?
Suddenly, these viruses are glued together
and this is even more efficient.
They can not do what they do normally.
They can not deplete the cell membrane
because they are identified or "tagged".
They are opsonized so phagocytes can come
and you eat.
We will talk about B cells in the future, but
what fascinates is that there are so many
combinations that are sufficient
to identify almost everything that exists in bodily fluids,
for which we still do not have all the answers.
We have not yet solved the problem of what is happening
when in fact things infiltrate the cells or do we have carcinogenic cells?
How do we snuff cells that have clearly deviated?